what is up and welcome to yet another
awesome tutorial series this series is
going to be covering the wx python
so what is wx python
wx python is a cross-platform toolkit
used for making gui's or graphical user
interfaces
uh this is done so the end user doesn't
actually have to communicate with the
python interpreter window right so so
nobody wants to like develop programs
and have to deal with like this or like
a dos you know prompt
it's just a plain more user-friendly way
to make programs and have users use
those programs
wx python itself is actually just kind
of like a wrapper around
the language c plus plus
now what that means is wx python itself
is not actually coded directly in python
uh instead it's more of like a python
interpreter kind of like you have a
python interpreter that you installed on
your system because your computer didn't
naturally understand python
so the main purpose with wx python is of
course to create windows looking windows
or as they're called in wx python in
programming frames
so with wx python you can make all kinds
of things like regular windows toolbars
scroll bars dialogs pop-ups buttons etc
and then also all these things like you
can use uh what are called event
handlers so like if the user clicks a
button it does this or clicks the window
it does this so you can do all kinds of
really cool things with these windows so
to get
wx python and start coding you're going
to have to visit
wxpython.org which i've pulled up here
and you'll want to scroll down to
download let's see if i can find it
myself download and you want stable
version not the development version so
we'll click that and here we go and this
is going to be the one that i want here
which is python 2.8 i want the 32-bit
version
to match my python you should pick
whatever
version of python you have however so
i'll just click that we'll download the
installer here
and here it comes now we'll just i'll
pause the video while we wait for this
to come on
once it's done obviously it's a download
so you just click it to open that up and
you'll just go ahead and hit run there
and here we go with the installer next
i'll accept
this just says where it's going to
install it next uh this is just to make
the uh yes we'll just go next and so now
it's going to install wx python on my
machine
and your machine
leave that at least
all right
and it's over here just
fixing up some of the files for us and
now
uh to make sure let's test the
installation so we'll restart our python
interpreter bring it over here and say
import wx
and as long as it doesn't yell at us
looks like we did it right
all right so now we're back to the
typical python idle
um and so
that concludes pretty much the
installation but again
just like my nltk tutorial i feel bad
making the first video being only the
installation so let's make
our first window at wx python so of
course to use wx python you'll need to
import wx subsequently now we're going
to start defining things that we want
our window to do
all right the next thing we want to do
is define app
and every wx python must have this
so that's just going to be wx dot app
the next thing that we're going to do is
we actually have to make the window or
as i refer to it earlier the frame so
we're just going to call it frame
equals wx dot frame
and then within the parameters you have
a few different things to call now
we're just going to say
the parameters within here we're just
going to say none negative one
and then we'll put the title of this
frame kind of like this has a title
which is
basically the name of the script and
then the location of the script you can
put this anything you want so we're
going to say uh this is the window title
we'll just put that in there you can
call it whatever the heck you want to
call it though
and basically what we're saying within
these parameters here we can go into
detail of them later but
basically
the
frame
is a widget and what we're saying here
is this is the
uh parent widget for any other widgets
so basically when we when you say none
there it just means that like it's a
parent widget itself
so kind of like the graphing tutorials
that i've got if you've been watching
those once you actually like define
something all we've done is defined it
we haven't actually called it up
so the next thing you want to do is call
it to show and that's just frame dot
show
and then finally
uh we'll just make this line here uh
app.main loop
and all this does is just kind of enter
us into like a main loop so everything
that happens uh during the event of like
this window is going to be captured but
again we'll go more into that later so
we'll just save this and we'll run it
and up pops our little window here and
as you can see we've got window title
and but that's it there's nothing in
here eventually we're going to have you
know menu items maybe something in here
and we'll do some cooler stuff but for
now this is what we have just a window
title
but already this is pretty darn
impressive
because there's all kinds of things to
it you've got just your you know even
just the title you got the little image
here you can move it around on your
screen you can resize it you do all
these things that even though like this
is such a stupid little window that
doesn't actually give us any utility
it's actually a lot of coding behind
even just this window so pretty cool
that we've already coded this window
so that's going to conclude this
tutorial
stay tuned for more tutorials on wx
python there's a lot of cool things that
you can do within here
and it's kind of enjoyable because
there's a lot of customization that you
can do along the way so
stay tuned and thanks for watching